why wait till the end of 2021 to
celebrate some of the year's best games
we're halfway through and there's
already some game of the year contenders
so here's a chance to look at some of
our favorite games from 2021
so far as chosen by the gamespot staff
who knows maybe there's a game on this
list you haven't checked out yet
and hey if you want don't forget to like
and subscribe
[Music]
we're back
ratchet
[Music]
who
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
valley's [ __ ] blazing still my heart
is blazing
if the words kill me i don't need a new
the smell of the cake
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
where's rose she's everything to me
i think it's time you left things in my
hands
go on rest now
attention all brawlers the knockout city
block party is about to pop off
where you and your crew can gear up and
throw down free
for limited time earning yourselves some
serious swagger
and big time rewards to set yourselves
apart in this metropolis of knockout
opulence
and this party won't stop cause season
one kicks off on may 25th
which means a whole lot more brawling is
coming your way
with a new map jukebox junction where
you need to watch your step
if you want to stay on your feet
[Music]
new league play where you can make a
name for yourself in 1v1 or 3v3 ranked
matches
new crew contracts where the more you
play together the more you can unlock
and a new way to play every single
week so what are you waiting for
brawlers grab your friends and hit the
knockout city block party
it's gonna be a blast literally
just think back to the very beginning
first thing that you can remember i'm
gonna send you there
every time that you blink you're gonna
jump forward in time
it could be a second could be five years
it's chloe your neighbor but
understand no matter how much you like
it
you're not going to be able to stay
penny
ready to come up here that's just how
this thing works
so if you understand what i'm saying um
blink over my hand here
you remember blinking don't you that
thing you did 30 000 times a day
would you do it already my arm's getting
[Music]
tired
it was always gonna end like this
all your hard work all your sacrifice
only sped up the process
[Music]
and now you find yourself alone
only death awaits
[Music]
[Music]
i found all areas
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you saw what was
what is and what would be
if you knew how it ends
would you change it
could you make the hard decisions
[Music]
and would you be strong enough to fight
so
if you learn from the past and act in
the present
you can rewrite the future
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh this looks bad
it's got serious hey everyone
you can give me all your desires watch
out
shadow's incoming give it everything
you've got guys
showtime
[Music]
what the hell ain't this stuff happening
all over japan
[Music]
i will consume all who oppose me no
matter who they are
we are the phantom thieves and all those
desires he stole
we're taking them all back
do you realize how dangerous a position
you're in right now
[Music]
and take back the people's hearts
yep
for real
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is for my fellow hunters
let's go
you listen to me now
fear my strength
don't take this personal i'll show no
[Music]
verses
[Music]
into the box corey dickerson and we are
set for baseball here this evening
and now pitch on the way
first pitch cutter that's by him for
strike one
seven o'clock
and he fouls this one off the offensive
game plan today is certainly to see the
ball
up this guy is known on the mound for
sinker change-up combination
he's going to try and establish down in
his own to get swinging a miss or ground
balls consistently
you have to find something above the
belt to get loose on
and this is taken for a call third
strike as the leadoff man is set down to
open up the ball game
next it'll be starling martay
changed up on him and dropped it in for
a cold strike
game time temperature tonight 62 degrees
but should drop
into the 50s before we're done a little
quick on that swing and he finds himself
behind owen too
lays off that time and it's one and two
fly ball out to straight away right
biscotti's there for it
and that's the second out of the inning
and to think there's still so many games
left to come
like psychonauts 2 metroid dread and
death loop just to name a few
now of course this is just some of what
the gamespot staff thinks
but what are your personal favorites so
far drop them in the comments below we
would love to know
like and subscribe for more games
coverage thanks for watching
[Music]